[Music]
gonna swing when it comes off that
corner
put it down
just let it go relax it's not gonna go
anywhere
that's a lot better there than
a minute ago swinging off the ladder
fortunately no accidents happen a couple
of times some good close reminders of
pay attention to what you're doing
because bad things happen really quick
first time's always the hardest
first time's always ours
and once we started
the second time worked pretty good
let it down
perfect the third time worked great so
it's just a matter of paying attention
to
each time you do something and then
modifying it a little bit
here we go floor is closing
wow
it's all closed up
wow
looks like a stage
come on up
wow look at it
new york apartment size
oh this is great andy
pretty solid you should be happy with
this
sometimes you travel out and bush your
remote areas and it's a real uneasy bad
vibe kind of a place
but this hunting platform
just has really good vibes to it
stop the last one
[Laughter]
that's it right here
you can still see over top of everything
yeah let me try sitting
what's really cool too is you can
stretch out and sleep and not worry
about rolling over
to put the time and energy into putting
something that's going to be really
useful to us and comfortable for us to
go back there and spend some time and
really utilize that piece of the country
that's that's going to pay off big for
us in the future
chris is in the basement
all right well i'm happy
i am very happy
tarzan make a new house
[Music]
you